foreign
has this Peloton let's get that on the
screen here Jordan so I love this
picture because it's the exact opposite
of a Peloton ad this is how pelotons
really look in our homes you know when
you see a Peloton and the ad it's like
this remarkable living space open space
yeah like so many windows right it's
like paradise and I've just added a bite
and there's always plenty of space for
the Peloton in the home in the Peloton
ad yes it looks pristine it's like they
have a special space just for their
Peloton but in real life here's what
happens your view is of a closet
and a wall yeah and it's just taking up
the space in this room right and so what
did Nicole say in her email to us from
Alabama Nicole said my husband got me a
Peloton for Christmas about three years
ago I never liked cycling and I didn't
ask for this gift every every time I
talk about getting rid of it or selling
it he'll use it and then it'll sit there
for another three to six months before
the cycle repeats again I enjoy running
and doing yoga as my form of exercise
which I do weekly but I feel the need to
make myself use this thing even though I
don't enjoy it one bit well just because
you use something is not a great reason
to hold on to it there are obvious
examples here that that make a lot of
sense like if you have seven spatulas in
your kitchen
well yeah you could I guess go out of
your way to use all of them every single
day or if it's within the seasonality
rule so yes I used the sixth spatula
within the last 90 days so I could hold
on to it but maybe they're still getting
in the way and so yes your husband
occasionally uses his Peloton but it's
getting in the way it's getting in his
way it's get certainly getting in your
way and can I also say what a weird gift
to get someone
right because what is the implication of
it like you need to lose weight that's
what it is you need to get more in shape
yeah and by the way if the person asks
for a gift like this or has been saying
oh I really want to get a Peloton then
it's a beautiful gift yeah but if you
surprise someone with a gym membership
that they didn't ask for if you surprise
them with a I don't know weight loss
book they didn't ask for or if you
surprise them with anything that appears
has the implication of I'm trying to
change you it leaves room for some
resentment even if that's not your
intention right yeah because to love
someone is to see them for who they are
and then you can support them if they
want to change on their own wonderful
now I'm not saying that was the case
here but I'm saying quite often we can
misunderstand how the gift will be
received by someone else I think we have
to take that into account like if I'm
getting you a gift how might they
experience this gift when I give it to
them
the Paradox of justificatory usage I had
a friend who back in the Blockbuster
Video days he'd rent a movie no lie and
he'd watch it twice and I asked him once
when he first told me this is that true
even for the bad movies and he said yeah
and I go why and he said to get my
money's worth oh so he would subject
himself to the two-hour experience of
re-watching a movie that he did not like
why because he wanted to justify to
himself the cost that he spent to rent
it and anytime you have to use something
just to justify having it
there's no use to it right the best
things to have are the things that you
are free to use and you don't have to
justify their existence in your life if
if you don't want it get rid of the
thing don't force yourself to use it in
the name of getting your money's worth
don't put yourself through some terrible
horrific self-stultifying experience
because well the money's already been
spent that's right the money has already
been spent why add your energy and your
time and your happiness to the waste
pile yeah wow you know this happened to
me Ryan I mean not the gift part but we
had a Peloton we used it for a while and
then Bex and I both decided that we
prefer to exercise in different ways and
it was weird because you're also paying
a monthly subscription with this so
you're paying every month you didn't
already pay for the Peloton but imagine
with the the movie yes you're paying for
your you paid for it once then you're
paying with your time your energy your
happiness as you said but imagine if you
had to keep paying for that movie be
over and over and over every month
that's what you're doing with the
Peloton here we realized like it wasn't
really worth our time it wasn't worth
our attention and there were ways that
inspired us to exercise more that didn't
involve this monthly subscription I'd
prefer to do those I always want to
default to the things that compel me
rather than the things that repel me and
I got to a point where I was yes I could
get on there every day I could force
myself to get onto the Peloton every day
and that sounds like what her husband is
doing he forced himself to get on there
occasionally I had a great streak going
it was like 70 weeks straight or
whatever but it was 70 weeks of forcing
myself and I realized like I've become a
slave to this expectation that I set for
myself yeah I became a slave to the
gamification of oh I need to keep my
streak going and then I intentionally
broke my streak I said I can't do this
anymore because the streak is making me
miserable yeah I'm playing a game I
don't want to play anymore and so I need
to walk away from this we sold the
Peloton we lost a little bit of money on
it but we got back our time and we found
something that was more compelling for
us so for me it was all about trash it I
didn't want to amass it anymore yeah and
if you're doing anything
just for the streak
like just for if it's only because of
the repetition and it's not really
giving you anything other than that OCD
relief of like ah I'm keeping it going
then yeah I would I would say that's
probably a bad reason to do anything
um I mean Mariah and I we have our
Peloton we use it a lot right we use it
you know three to six times a week
um I
if I got rid of the Peloton I'd have to
find a substitution so like I asked
myself like if it's spontaneously
combusted would I buy it again and the
answer is like yeah we would absolutely
get it again so uh yeah I mean it sounds
like this isn't adding a ton of value to
you Nicole
um
you know if your husband if it's if you
leave it up to him it's probably never
going to get sold so maybe you can go to
him and with a different solution and
say hey uh I know we're not going to get
100 of her money back on this but we
could at least you know recoup some of
it and here's what we can do with that
money yes and maybe that would help him
see the benefit benefit of it because
right now it sounds like Nicole's
husband has uh the thought of like hey I
paid money for that
um I don't want to get rid of it because
then I feel like I wasted money so I'm
gonna get on it once every three months
or once every six months whatever it is
to make myself feel like I'm using it
um there might be a a there just might
be a better use of that money that maybe
would make him feel better to get rid of
it rather than holding on to it
and add to that a better use of that
space time and energy too right you
might be able to say if I I only can get
half the money back but also here's what
I do with that space I free up that time
I free up that energy I free up yeah yes
you're asking yourself is this the best
use of this money the monthly amount of
money and also the money we would get
back from selling it is this the best
use of this space in this room I think
you know the answer to that for you the
answer it sounds like is no for Ryan the
answer is yes and so there's no wrong
answer here right it's just being honest
with yourself is this the best use of my
space of my attention of my time of my
money this is the perfect time for the
repurchase Rule and so my question to
you Nicole and I would ask your husband
this question as well if that thing were
to get lost today if it were to Simply
get stolen from your house would you
replace it and if not well you can let
it go yeah I Josh I saw you putting on a
ski mask it was like What if that thing
just happened
[Laughter]
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free